there's only one way to get out of here
let's go murder something with our hands
and doing what to who yes get up ah
[Music]
don't look for any fruit that seems out
of place okay mark seriously same team
here man I mean I know that if he's a
banana he's gonna be standing upright
which looks really [ __ ] stupid are we
supposed to change this mess way too
small like I mean you can if you want to
all right then never yeah so tiny
hiding behind around the
huh shadowy breaking the rules you have
to be in plain sight alright look for
something super awkward and giggling to
itself okay large okay I'm gonna go down
to the but I'm not really for sure on
that okay I'm going down I'm just
carrying up some room sorry I'm sorry I
have anger alright I'm here are you know
just good I was just I was trying to
mess with their heads you know ed was
thoroughly messed with that's why I had
to shoot you cuz I was angry that you
did this to me
that's not bad some bad what's not bit
behind Nick is not bad Nick I've been
following you this whole time
I'm currently I'm doing a good job
was going on take you to small objects
I'm guarding the entrance to the bottom
floor all right everyone take a photo
well everyone take a floor oh do you see
me
no move I'm just bullying props you guys
go to each subsequent floor and start
bullying okay
use your bully voice you know you mean
business smash
I got everything upstairs looks pretty
dumb so it always pretty bomb stairs
looks pretty normal
yeah each of us throws a grenade in each
floor I like this man okay you wanna try
it
by all means yeah if you if you hit
props that are not actual people than
you'd lose hell well manners come on you
die probably literally not even I hear
music
do you where's the music coming from
Adam are you again that's that's the
part that sucks about that probably
should are you inside or outside
[Music]
today yeah inside whatnot and I know
you're immediately figure I'm lying to
you but I'm not I'm inside inside I mean
you've never really given us a reason to
trust you I'm inside if you want to come
find me I will patiently wait for you
arrive and then when you get here I will
heckle you I will make you feel stupid
and that's perfectly okay with me uh-huh
okay yeah all right all right all right
typically I chase you around and giggle
at you with this round I'm playing it by
the books right mm-hmm I'm just taking
it one step at a time
I warm our market the razors in Oh
the way that I'm positioned I can't tell
I am very much our peen right now I am
the object so you don't have eyes
because you're like are you the object
that doesn't have eyes guys he's not the
human he doesn't have eyes he that rules
that out now here's a tip guys I'm not a
human all right okay all right that
narrows it down I know I thought the
three switch rule applied here switch
I don't know was that a thing I mean
yeah I mean that what dick ssin did say
that was kind of I mean you like me to
switch I could all you around and heckle
you or I could sit here and blend it
matter at this point
okay I'll heckle then I'll heckle
absolutely no way no right just got to
take it real nice and slow don't want to
get caught on my way out to work all
right
Lise police are everywhere the 405 is
insane where you are and then I'll help
I don't think I'm a plain sight
early in spirit yeah I mean now you're
in plain sight that's a plain sight okay
know what we man it's like hiding behind
objects were like the hunters can't
really see okay you're fine
yeah okay I had a good plan I just
couldn't get up to where I was trying to
go hmm
I don't know why the hell had that
stupid I don't know why yeah like it's a
thing you know it's the thing my heart
was beating pretty fast but I'm glad but
oh yeah was it that nerve-racking that
was nerve-racking man huh okay
God whatever whatever it was it was
probably stupid it was good we should do
a triple hide there we should do what oh
yes it's an unfair place to be hiding
the note yourself in the back to are
there but it's in plain sight oh sure
yeah hey look you'll see the footage
you'll know what I did and then you will
do one of them facepalm things you know
no I'll probably just report your
channel for bullying fringes on my
rights
[Laughter]
no this doesn't look right I think I
played this enough to know that this
looks out of the ordinary whatever no
nice slip between your legs that made
you look dumb
sheriff's on this to replace that will
look horrifically dumb mmm
one day all night smells more hunters
what I mean day this Maps big you have a
chance to plenty of a chance uh-huh yeah
yeah I don't know I just wasted my
grenades I did your name I accidentally
slipped on the right and click you know
it happened this yeah yeah yeah sure
yeah I would admit people have walked by
me people have people walk by me say
you're in the doting then yeah sounds
like he's in the building
yes'm alright let's go find him hmm I
would venture to say he give clues as to
where I am I help people
you're doing well there they come
walking by a little baby that is the
cinnamon toast Ken hiding spot no stop
saying go right now you're not going
anywhere just trying to throw us off the
scent there we go they may have already
gone out I don't know now they haven't I
got I got a watchful eye on it all right
oh yeah wait we only have two you just
smash their heads you're welcome
okay okay whose last atom ash that was
Aaron well you guys are off venture
enough doing your little thing I found a
crate hiding spot oh great yeah no it's
probably not the VINs cuz we know where
to look
yeah [ __ ] I can't use this ladder to
save my [ __ ] life okay I don't mean to
be a negative Nancy or anything but
they're gonna know what Thank You Adam
hear me again they being one of these
road sign things who's closing this door
over here now you're good now you're
good okay no I don't know if I would say
good okay that's good me oh yeah that's
Oh
[Music]
Oh God